my latest book club selection American  dirt this book stirred up a lot of  controversy you resisted because you  thought you were the wrong taller we  faced it head-on by confronting the  tough questions where did you write this  book for because it wasn't a book for me  Oprah was this a wake up call for you  how many people felt your mind was  changed your heart was opened we can do  this without having to silence anyone  and we journey to the border to talk  about the trauma of coming to America  [Music]  we all know this is an inflammatory  issue why should we care there's a  humanitarian crisis going on yes and  people just keep shopping yeah so it's  not happening what this has done for me  it has opened my eyes in ways that only  books can do  you